we all have an obligation to make money
the large majority of us have an
obligation to make money and whenever
you attach obligation to anything you
love there's always going to be an
element of it feeling like a chore i
think probably what's been slightly
missold is this idea that you're going
to have a big passion something you love
it's going to be monetizable
and you're never going to hate it or
burn out like we need to preserve the
fact that and we need to understand the
fact that you can love what you do and
feel incredibly privileged to do what
you do and still not wake up every
morning and be like
skipping out the door
hello and welcome back to deep dive the
ongoing podcast where every week i get
the chance to speak to entrepreneurs
authors creators and other inspiring
people and we find out how they got to
where they are and the strategies and
tools that we can learn from them to
apply to help live our best lives and
today what you're about to hear is a
conversation between me and grace
beverly grace is an entrepreneur and
author of this excellent book working
hard hardly working grace is interesting
because she's like an og influencer from
like back in the day and for i think
three years she grew a fitness fitness
account on instagram on youtube to like
stupidly high proportions but then she
actually decided to kind of scrap the
being an influencer lifestyle in favor
of starting two businesses while she was
studying full-time at oxford university
one of them is called a tala which is a
sustainable activewear brand and the
other one is called shreddy which is
like this workout app for working out
and fitness and like sells physical
products and these two are like
incredibly interesting businesses which
grace has managed to create in her early
20s and i think she's now just 25 years
old having written a book it's a best
seller just crushing it across all these
different fields of life and so we talk
a lot about the idea of entrepreneurship
we talk a lot about productivity and the
balance between productivity and
self-care and we kind of dig into a
little bit of grace's history as to how
she started doing the influencer thing
and posting fitness videos on instagram
and why she ultimately decided that that
was not the life for her so incredibly
enjoyable conversation uh super nice of
grace to hop on the podcast and for us
to have a conversation in person and
yeah the book is sick i've read it
recently and i'm just like blown away by
how many interesting ideas she's got in
the book you know this idea of
productivity and the idea of self-care
and how we can kind of balance this
theoretical fine line between the two so
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
between me and grace beverly it seems
like you're just doing a ton of stuff i
kind of wanted to talk about all of the
things that you're doing
but i thought the place we could start
was
your background as a chorister
oh and he's going way back yeah because
it's like research so
when i was year seven to nine i was in
the south end
and i wanted to ask what is that like
being in that kind of world well i
actually think that if you trace
like
my almost manic obsession with being
busy all the time not intentionally i
know it's a bad thing i know i don't
actually want it but like i will
shamelessly say that my like self-worth
is entirely like kind of
probably like related to my like
productivity slash how busy i am i know
it's wrong it's still the case we're
working on it but i would say actually i
went to salisbury which is where i was
at chorister when i was i auditioned
when i was eight i went when i was nine
and so you're doing that alongside
school which means you're
rehearsing for two hours in the morning
and
every other day about it's about four to
five hours in the evening because it's
rehearsal and service this is the
salsbury cathedral the souls cathedral
so
every day and then on the weekends you
do either
saturday night and sunday night
or you do friday night and sunday
morning
that's pretty intense so yeah so it's
about 20 hours on top of your school
work
so i think so from the age of nine
i
was doing yeah you you get up early you
do your two hours before school you're
45 hours after school and then your
weekends and you also
don't have school holidays you don't
have school holidays it's starting to
sound a bit
illegal yeah does almost like child
labor
well it was um by choice and also you go
to the private school for
um hugely discounted so because you have
to go to that school to be part of the
choir anyway that's kind of what i did
from when i was nine to when i was 13
and then left but was always a music
scholar after that so always had kind of
a music scholar essentially would get
a huge percentage of money off and go to
for the school i was at but in return
for doing lots of music things
so
concerts helping younger students like
lots of things but you you play your
jews so was it like singing or musical
instruments as well or what was your
what was your jam my instrument ranking
was first instrument was voice then
violin then piano and then i actually
played the drums for a while
yeah and then you got a choral
scholarship to oxford it's my
understanding yes yeah yeah and then
that would have been pretty intense as
well because yeah everyone i know who
was inquired just like all of their
evenings seemed to be yeah yeah yeah
choral scholarship to oxford and then
i actually gave up my scholarship after
first year because
i had also started my first business yep
you're not really meant to be doing that
anyway oh yeah good because they don't
allow you to technically work there's a
there's a rule people think that's right
yeah i think they
they judge it well i tried to give them
no excuse to ever think that it was
compromising yep anything like i did not
miss a single deadline throughout my
whole time there not even like
due date deadlines like
the weekly essays like i didn't i just
made it a point to not miss anything
yeah because otherwise i knew they'd
have an excuse to be like
why you why are you doing this yeah
so yeah that was kind of yeah yeah on
mind i just didn't ask for permission i
just did the thing i imagine that's how
you started off well did you email your
like director of studies and be like hey
can i have permission to launch ready no
no because
when i started the first business it was
because i'd had an email from the bursa
saying that my student finance hadn't
come through and if it wasn't paid by a
month later then i'd be expelled from
the university oh so i was that was so i
was like suspended that was my
suspension email and so that's how i
originally started it yeah because i
needed some money i wasn't going to
email and be like hey you're about to
kick me out but can i have permission to
work please yes quite yeah emails from
the burst are never a fun no
they're always a bit
so are you doing any of the music stuff
these days or is everything else in your
life sort of taken over that
i don't do nearly as much as i should
should
in terms of i love it yeah
and it was my entire life from so
obviously did the chorus to thing then i
did the music scholarship thing and then
i went to the royal academy of music
alongside secondary school oh you did
that as well damn i don't know that
that's cool
so
that like as in my whole life revolved
around it for a very long time and so
it's so it was such a huge part of my
life so i would love to do more of it
but i don't prioritize it so when i say
should not in terms of obligation but in
terms of you should spend time doing
things you love
my housemates know i'm really stressed
if i'm playing the piano oh they're like
do you want to go and play them yeah
which will be because i'm
yeah very stressful so it's good to
stress that but i should do it more so
the reason i ask about the music stuff
is that in your book and i was listening
to your interview with stephen as well
you kind of talk about the idea of
purpose and like passion
and those are like difficult things to
find that sort of intersection of the
venn diagram for i remember you saying
something that like you found that your
kind of passion purpose wasn't in the
influencer gracefully uk life it was
more in the branding marketing side yeah
and i was kind of thinking but like if
you're like where does music come into
this if at all
amongst the sort of grace beverly
entrepreneur podcaster author scene so i
don't think that i necessarily do many
things for fun now that don't make me
money and i feel like that's inherently
problematic and not something i agree
with
and i feel like music to me was always
something that actually i mean it kind
of
made money from when i was like nine
yeah
but
it was so part of my life and it never
made it was never kind of like what was
making me money if that made sense and
it never evolved into something that was
my career in that way and i think that's
what maintains my love of it so much and
i don't know if that's slightly strange
because obviously we do encourage like i
don't know i feel like i talk about this
in the book too i feel like we talk a
lot about this idea of some
big passion and big purpose that you
that almost if you're
coming into the workforce and you don't
have something like that you feel in
some way inferior and i actually think
that my big passion
which probably was music
i love more as being a big passion
rather than being something something to
monetize and the thing that i'm
passionate about that i do monetize is
all of the kind of like branding
marketing
that type of stuff i guess they're
they're separate and for some reason in
my head that's always really made sense
to me and that's kept the joy of it i
also think i probably burnt out in it
quite a lot for you know when i was
younger yeah because i was doing so much
of it and then just thought this is
probably not going to be yes the rest of
my life absolutely definitely want to
put a bookmark on the burnout
conversation i've been doing a bunch of
research into for my book and into
intrinsic extrinsic motivation and stuff
and there seems to be a lot of
scientific and anecdotal evidence from
everyone that when you have something
that's fun and you add money to it
even if you really enjoy the thing
there's some aspect of it of like now
doing it for money which sort of takes a
little bit or a lot of the joy out of it
what's been your experience with that
with the sort of entrepreneurship
podcasty because he said like everything
you do is for money i think it's kind of
the same for me almost everything i do
is monetized in some way or another yeah
and i i often feel that like
i feel like i don't have anything that i
do purely for fun which is which is like
it's such a huge privilege to be able to
monetize anything that you love like i
think that we talk about it a lot when
we're we almost see it as like kind of
like wishy-washy but it is very much
like a it's a like
very middle-class
kind of concept because you're you're
essentially
expecting people to be able to like
monetize something that is
you know that's not something they have
to do to make money and i
kind of think that obviously
whenever
we all have an obligation to make money
well the large majority of us have an
obligation to make money and whenever
you attach obligation to anything you
love
there's always going to be an element of
it feeling like a chore i think probably
what's been
slightly missiled
is this idea
that you're going to have a big passion
something you love it's going to be
monetizable
and you're never going to hate it or
burn out like we need to preserve the
fact that and we need to understand the
fact that you can love what you do and
feel incredibly privileged to do what
you do and still not wake up every
morning and be like
skipping out the door
so excited to go to it and i think when
we have this idea that you do have to do
that
it
is inevitably going to cause us both
like
anxiety
because
we feel ungrateful and we feel like it's
not feeling right and all of that
and also
going to come with this kind of
constantly feeling like we're doing it
wrong because ultimately if you're doing
something every day
and there's any element of obligation in
there
you're going to
not always want to do it even if it's
just based on your mood
yeah and it seems like a lot of people
that comment on this feel that this is a
fairly modern phenomenon where back in
the day like our parents generation it
was just a given that oh you go to work
it's a thing you have to do everyone's
got to work kind of vibe
and sometimes when i talk to my mom and
she's like because you know i left
medicine to do this youtubery stuff
often she'll say something like you know
you've got to grow up some sometime we
all have to work and
almost like work and fun are like
different things but i feel like
millennial gen z the whole vibe is oh i
don't just want to go to work to make
money if i have the option of course all
the privileged conversation aside if i
have the option i would like to go to
work to have fun to have purpose to be
passionate about it yeah i completely
agree i also think that part of what's
being tied into this is the fact that
actually for our parents generation the
whole concept that actually if you
worked for
if you worked hard
for 10 years not even 10 years the
expectation was less than that if you
worked hard for a number of years you'd
be able to
feed yourself clothe yourself
feed your children clothe your children
and buy a house oh yeah
and none of that actually is the reality
anymore
like what the first home buyer is now
mid-30s mid to late 30s i i believe so i
think there's also part of this
conversation that's kind of tying into
it that's saying
actually even if i hate what i do and i
do it for
20 30 years i'm not even guaranteed to
be able to pay my bills
so there's part of that that's kind of
tying into and being like well i might
as well try and do something i love and
actually what we're very much being sold
online as well and what is probably
quite a lot of it is true is actually
the fact that
if you're doing something alongside that
that's not necessarily a traditional
role
that's you know
something online some sort of side
hustle some drop shipping some whatever
actually those are the routes that are
making people enough money to be able to
do that and so there's this kind of
twisted and like new perception of
actually well if we if we play by all
the rules and we don't even get the
reward that we were kind of promised
this like social construct that you'll
be able to do all of that and provide
for yourself then we might as well
be doing something
that we love this kind of like working
for yourself thing as well and i do
think that kind of ties in quite heavily
two
i love the idea that we now believe that
we can do something we love and make
money i also think that it you know as
we've talked about it can be quite toxic
too yeah but i do think that definitely
ties into it it's a very different
social environment
yeah the whole side hustle thing so from
when i was 17 and i read the four-hour
work week i was like all right cool
forward passive income blah blah blah i
spoke to a bunch of doctors who i knew
and i was like you know how much do you
really enjoy your job if you won the
lottery would you would you would you
still do medicine and half of them were
like i would quit immediately and the
other half were like i'd go part-time
and i was like why didn't you go
part-time and they were like well
because i i need to pay the bills
mortgage kids kids et cetera et cetera
and so in my mind i was like cool
clearly the answer here is that like i
want to be able to do medicine for fun
and i want to have enough streams of
passive income on the side to be able to
be able to kind of clothe myself feed
myself and buy a house and do all those
things because it seems like medicine in
the uk is not necessarily the path to
that right now yeah but then there's
some it's it is somewhat unfashionable
to suggest the whole side hustle thing
these days
and given that
you were i guess
i guess when i was at university you
were like one of the og influencer side
hustler type people and
certainly in the book you kind of talk
about that a little bit
how do you think about this balance
between
people should have cyto people could
have side hustles if they want to make
streams of income to become financially
free etc etc versus the kind of backlash
to that of like oh but now you're
telling people to work a second job in
the evenings and that's bad yeah so i
think that it's exactly that it's not
black and white and i think that when we
present it online as black and white and
actually if you're using any hours in
the evening to relax rather than using
those three hours to be building your
own shopify page and making this much
money then you're you know you don't
like time you just like discipline like
all of these things
i think that it can both be true that
you can make lots through that and
create a great life for yourself through
that and that'll also be really kind of
this kind of toxic tie that i'd admit
very much myself that i kind of have in
my own like head between
your productivity and your self-worth
and your ability to monetize every
single moment of your time i think that
i will be the first to say that side
hustles will be
are an incredible way to
make money outside of your main job or
for me it was when i was a student or
even before that i was babysitting every
night or doing music tutoring like all
of these things i kind of when i got
into making money it was actually
because i became obsessed with the fact
that you know if i get 20 pounds a month
from my parents i can make 25 pounds an
hour a night from babysitting so i've
already doubled my technical income for
the month and just got completely
obsessed with that idea and then when i
worked at ibm i was doing the kind of
instagram stuff on the side and selling
stuff and that kind of just snowballed
and so i can't sit here and say like oh
no cyclops is really toxic
i think that it's marketed very
toxically and i think this we do need to
kind of question the idea that actually
the amount of money we can make is
capped only by our time
or yeah and i also think that we can
acknowledge that actually creating
separate passive streams of income is a
really important and really effective
way to make more money and i also think
that now we're in an era where that you
know
privilege is more important to talk
about than ever but also at the same
time
the online space is
has hugely democratized
starting a business in the way that the
barriers to entry to starting a business
are way way way lower yeah and so it's
kind of i just think that as long as we
talk about it with the nuance of the
whole conversation then great i think
when we sell it as this kind of like
you're relaxing in the evening that's
why you don't have a house and that's
why you're not driving a lamborghini i
think that's kind of i mean it just it
sells on instagram doesn't it yeah no
absolutely like there's always a middle
way with these sorts of things you
mentioned that your ability to monetize
your free time
is not really capped by time uh
necessarily these days what like what
are the other factors do you think that
kind of go into this and i guess i'm
asking because i often come at this
because i teach a course teaching people
how to be part-time youtubers and
there's always this tension between
wanting to be encouraging that hey
anyone can succeed on youtube because
technically they can but also this
recognition that like i succeeded on
youtube because i had cambridge medical
school like as my brand brand of hashtag
for like three freaking years and
there's loads of unfair advantages and
privileges that play into it and at the
same time yes theoretically someone in
any position could succeed and
yeah yeah i mean
i don't think i've ever cracked that i
try to
probably to an annoying extent
contextualize everything i do with my
privilege
like i um
you know like all the
huge list of i mean i have a whole
chapter on it yeah so it's like i try
and contextualize that probably to the
point of like virtue signaling
beyond that
what i can do is share my journey i
can't be unborn
like that's my that's obviously like you
know i can't be on one i can't change
that background what i can do is
fiercely contextualize so that i'm not
saying
actually you over there the only reason
you're not in my position is because you
didn't work hard enough i think that
beyond privilege as well i was in the
right place at the right time with
social media
i you know went to oxford again as you
said like a huge like put that on a
youtube video so many people are going
to watch it like still my you know
content had to be entertaining it had to
be informative it had to take planning i
was uploading three times a week
you know every week at university and
all of these things so it's like
again as long as you include the whole
conversation and it can texturize the
whole conversation i think there is this
tendency online to just see things as
one way or another and that's a really
easy way to call people out and cancel
people and all of these things whereas
actually if you're able to talk about
the whole conversation as long as i'm
not sitting here saying like
exactly that like if you look at you the
only reason you're not where i am is
because you didn't work hard enough like
that's obviously not true yeah it's
quite i think the whole thing is about
enabling
actual conversations on social media
rather than stunted conversations based
on a one-sided way we want to see things
i'd love to talk a little bit about the
the sort of graceful uk saga oh yeah
yeah you're up and talking about that
because
yeah like i at university everyone like
when i was at university everyone knew
who you were and when i started on
youtube like oh so you're trying to be
like graceful uk i was like
no because
i am a com complete the opposite of kind
of fitness influencer kind of vibes what
was it that made you decide to start and
like i guess what was the story of the
the original the early days of
of your kind of influencer career and
then i'd love to talk about why that
seems to have taken a pause and you
deleted the channel and like yeah yeah
the arc of grace for uk so let's sketch
a timeline yep
february 22nd 2015 my instagram account
starts at this stage it's
a jumble of letters is the name i don't
post my face yeah i didn't post my face
until i had ten thousand followers i
think it was how old were you at the
time
just turned 18. okay
and the whole concept of that was that i
consistently tried to start a fitness
journey and consistently failed and so
the whole idea of that was that i would
be tracking my journey online and just
like as you see now accounts of people
being like this is what i had for lunch
today
this is how i went to the gym like this
is what i did at the gym like all of
these various different things
so that was how the account started and
continued that way probably about for
about two years year and a half okay so
just a purely a personal thing yeah i
actually changed my name to my name
about seven months eight months in
and started showing my face it was a
terribly kept secret at school i got a
lot of [ __ ] for that oh yeah yeah so i
that's when i started working at ibm
my first monetization of anything was
that when in about
november i believe it was i was every
single weekend when i was at iebn i
would because i was posting content in
the week i would
spend like the saturday cooking up about
15 recipes and i'd spend the sunday
filming a load of workout videos like
that was
so i'd spend a huge amount of time
creating content the weekend and then i
post it throughout the week because that
was because i was going into work at
what like some stupid corporate hour
like 5 a.m and coming home after dark as
well in the winter in the uk it gets you
know you can't take any content that's
kind of how i was doing it
and then so i realized that that kind of
wasn't maintainable so i turned some of
those i the first product i ever made
was a uh recipe pdf so it was all of my
recipes so healthy versions of unhealthy
recipes the ones that i'd kind of used
put them into two different pdf sold
them five pounds each on my shopify
store that i literally just built with a
theme and
made a logo on canva and just kind of
did all of that super simple put a
digital downloads thing on so someone
would check out and it would get sent to
their email really easy side hustle pro
how many followers were you on at the
time when i started that probably about
thirty thousand
so you got from zero to thirty five
thousand just kind of posting working
she just like these yes yeah just like
almost like a diary of my journey
workout recipes and i also think that
very much golden age of instagram at the
time think of tik tok now
algorithm is very different pushing out
to a lot more audiences and also
influencers were people
were usually like singers models
actresses like there was they weren't
digital first there was a reason you
knew them and then you followed them on
social media there weren't as many and
there would have been like zoella and a
few others but there weren't as many
kind of creator first digital first and
so i think that like mine was very
unpolished like it was probably the most
aggressively anaesthetic instagram page
you could possibly imagine we've never
transitioned out of that and essentially
that was that was kind of what i did
then i went to university so went to
oxford 2016 a year after working at ibm
i think i had nearly a hundred thousand
followers at that point and i started to
have drips and drabs of like first brand
deals but at the time you would have to
like now
you're you know you might have a few
thousand followers you'll be able to get
gifting for you know won't have to post
for it like all of these things at the
time you'd have to beg a company to even
send you gifting to do like 23 posts um
it was like a very different so like the
money wasn't as much there or at least
they weren't paying me
so
then when i made my second pdfs which
was when i really started
making a lot of money was
when i got that email from the bursa at
oxford saying you have been suspended
from the university because you haven't
paid your fees and i was obviously just
relying on student finance to go from
the student finance into the oxford bank
account like i wasn't going to have any
say in that and so i completely freaked
out and that i was out at dinner when i
got that email
and
that night i basically wrote a workout
guide okay until
like 5 a.m okay because i was completely
freaked out and because i'd sold
i'd say probably like a few hundred
copies of the five pound ebooks i was
like if i send sell a few hundred copies
of this 35 pound eight week workout
guide that's gonna be a good few
thousand pounds yeah that could even get
me to
nine grand potentially with double the
following like all of this so that was
in my mind like i will i had a month
essentially either student finance comes
in or you're gone yeah they seemed they
were nice about it they were really nice
about it but i was quite freaked out as
i'm sure you can imagine and so did that
and then said hey guys i'm studying this
workout guide on
january the something classic fitness
culture and the fitness industry i'd say
was very different at the time starting
that in january and it's going to be on
sale on
26th of december i used some sort of
restricted
supply type thing i was like it's only
going to be available to this many
people or like you get the extra thing
for this many people so then on the day
i remember
it was insane i remember on the day i
checked the like dashboard and
it was
i think i'd made like 15 grand that day
and i was like whoa and i remember i was
at the theater with my family because it
was like it was boxing day and so this
was our like christmas family thing
and i remember like looking down at my
phone and seeing that dashboard and like
hide it like just like putting it away
so i was like that was an obscene amount
of money like and i remember my sister
looks over and goes like is that how
much you've made from instagram this
year or from your like pdfs this year
and i
i was like
no that's actually the one i like put on
sale today
she goes
to my mum she was like
grace has made 15 grand today and my mom
goes well grace can buy the ice creams
at the interval
this was my this was my
fire into the um the kind of like
instagram monetization all of this world
i had never seen like that was insane to
me that was my entire my salary at ibm
for that internship was 18 grand it's a
school leaver scheme anyone can apply
it's called the future scheme and i then
basically made that in a day with profit
margin 100 because it's a pretty f so
there's no marginal cost anyway fast
forward because you don't need to hear
it in that much detail
that i'd then around that time i'd also
started a youtube channel and the only
reason i'd started a youtube channel was
because on instagram at the time you
could only do 50 15 second videos
and i was doing lots of workout videos
and so to have a whole workout into 15
seconds
impossible i would be like
doing one hip thrust and then you'll be
on to the next video and so i
literally started a youtube my first few
vlogs you can't see them anymore i'm
afraid but they were literally i'd be
like hey guys i'm going to the gym then
you'd see my feet stop stop walking to
the gym then you'd see my workout and
then and it would just have like music
over it and then it'd be like okay guys
bye and that would be the whole i
thought that's how vlogs worked because
i didn't actually watch youtube and then
so that kind of grew from that when i
started at
oxford to because i couldn't record
content a lot of the time i was kind of
like well my content is going to have to
pivot it's essentially going to have to
just be what i'm doing and so that's how
it started for the next three years
all of my content three days a week was
me sitting in the same like university
dorm room being like
i'm writing an essay again
and that was the entire genre of content
because it was like this is what i'm
doing and i feel like that was probably
quite a blessing as well because i think
if you get successful on youtube
lots of people quit their jobs or you
know move into a super fancy apartment
or any of this three years the initial
three years of my content
growing up to however many subscribers
or whatever was always just me sitting
in the same place being like guys i'm
doing an essay and here's the yogurt i'm
having for my fridge that's my dinner
and so it was quite yeah that was kind
of my whole brand and then okay then we
come to the transition a few questions
on this before the transition even now
where the sort of influencer culture is
like way more of a thing than it was six
seven years ago
it would still be weird for someone in
sixth form to be like you know what i'm
gonna start posting workout videos yeah
and they'd be like
like one of my friends like it's it's
weird enough for someone to make videos
on youtube
teaching educational topics yeah yeah
and yet post i had no purpose yeah so
there was i was adding value to no one
okay but like how did you get over the
fear i guess
it seems to be a thing that holds a lot
of people back from i guess putting
themselves out there so probably worth
noting that i had about a year of on
instagram before i started on the
youtube so yeah that's where yeah like
with the instagram stuff well so even
that that wasn't
it was i was basically using it as a
diary
it was like i've done this workout today
the this is what i'm eating today i went
shopping today like it was like a diary
so it wasn't necessary it was weird like
it was definitely weird and i got a lot
of [ __ ] from it at school like how did
people at school react
not very well
not very well i yeah i i mean not
necessarily to my face i heard a lot
about it we laugh about it now okay it's
a strange thing to do and yeah that's
kind of how it started but then i had
like i was kind of eased into it with
that year of instagram and then youtube
was just not really even vlogs i would
say two words and then move on to the
next thing and then by that stage i
probably had enough external validation
from what i was doing that it made sense
to kind of transition into vlogs and
that type of content that had again i
used to look at my vlogs and i'd be like
even now i look at my vlogs and it's
what
you know i'd say three and a half years
now since i was on youtube
and now i'll post a vlog and it will
still you know still a hundred thousand
people will watch it which was kind of
what my vlog i don't know i don't know
how many views my vlogs were doing kind
of back then but even that it's like i'm
adding
no value to your life
i think it's like as in it's such a
privilege to have people be so
supportive and love to kind of watch
that when genuinely as you say it's not
educational content it's not tuition
it's not anything it's terrible angles
of a camera and like
yeah whatever is happening that day yeah
so you had like i know a bunch of
youtube i i i feel this myself where
when i post a vlog
i kind of can't believe people are
watching it i'm like
whatever i'm finding this boring so
definitely
so i guess
so you said it was it was several months
before you showed your face on instagram
yeah and then you changed your name like
to grace fit yeah what was that
transition like where you suddenly
started showing your face oh i just
thought i literally i all i thought was
well people know now i'm getting [ __ ]
for it anyway it's not helping like what
at this stage when i started to gain a
bit of traction i was like well it's
gonna be much easier for me to continue
doing this and continue gaining traction
if like i'm it's also not a selfie with
my head cut off yeah okay so it sounds
like that was the time when you sort of
realized the quick business value of the
page yeah kind of business value but
also i think we forget that like at the
beginning of instagram
because there was no digital first
talent even having like
i remember i don't know even having like
50 likes on facebook was like huge like
it was like normal
like it's probably like shameless actual
external validation based on like that
it wasn't it wasn't monetized for a long
time after i would say it would probably
be being like oh my god this is so cool
yeah okay look how cool i look yeah that
was probably probably just some
shameless vanity and did you start
getting so it's it sounds like people at
school were like less supportive than
would have been ideal
did you get i was only at school for
like two months after i'd even started
it before a levels did you get any kind
of hate from strangers on the internet
oh you will always get hate from
strangers at the internet yeah what was
that like in the early days i mean in
the early days it was all mainly like
body shaming and
i think it was all it was all just kind
of like body shaming and being like oh
you're ugly
like it wasn't very inventive right it's
become more and more inventive that i'm
very lucky to like because i don't put
out a lot of content now usually a hater
would get bored
before yeah so so they they'll just
they'll just leave you yeah yeah exactly
so so i don't get i don't get much hate
to talk about which is amazing but like
how did you deal with it at the time
because and again i asked because about
like 80 percent of the students that i
teach youtube to are just like oh my god
haters and like yeah struggling with
that i think i was so
i think probably i've i can't remember
that much how i dealt with it i think it
probably hurt more the things that were
in real life but then actually the ones
online there was so uninventive that
like
calling me ugly like as in that's fine
you know like it's not nice to hear but
it's also like not the end of the world
and then i think it would move on it
would get more inventive as i was
putting more content out because you can
actually see my personality
okay you know inventive as in well just
as in like it would be
you know just like more more depth to
the insults but then it's kind of just
like i don't know there was definitely a
period of time where i was obsessed with
checking kind of like gossip forums like
i've i've always been and i've talked
about this in my move off youtube i'm
a people pleaser in a lot of ways just
like personality-wise a lot of us are
and i'm i am definitely
and
i
being a people-pleaser whilst
broadcasting to millions of people
quite incompatible because if as a
percentage of people you're always going
to for example like
20 of people aren't gonna like you or
maybe more i don't know then if like the
higher obviously if that's then a
million people then 200 000 people are
not going you know like that's quite a
lot of people so it's quite incompatible
i'd say in like terms of personality
types and i'd think that actually one
part of that was that i was so obsessed
with checking these gossip forums when i
was i'd say my first few years at
university
because i thought originally
because i was you know i would always
look at which thumbnails did well which
types of content did well i was doing it
very strategically as well as sharing
content you know like sharing blogs and
all of those things that like fit into
my schedule i would obviously do more of
the things that worked and do less of
the things that didn't work and so
originally when i started checking
gossip forums it was very much
how
can i make my content better but
obviously
making my content better by changing my
entire personality probably not that
preferable yeah like it's it's not gonna
like
it's not gonna end well yeah i just
think i got to a point where i actually
got to a point where i was so it would
bring me down so much and on these ba
i'd have a bad day so i'd get like a bad
mark in an essay or you know whatever
and i'd be like well i'm already having
a terrible day so i might as well check
these gossip forums but ultimately at
the end like i realized that actually no
matter what i was doing in the direction
of what these people wanted or against
it it wasn't changing so it was kind of
like this content's going to be out
there anyway i might as well
not feel violently sick every time i you
know search my name up and so i just you
know i think also as you mature you
realize not to scratch itches that are
going to hurt you
and i've matured in a way that i
like
and like if i spent my entire life
caring what other people
thought then it's not going to change
anyone else's life the only person's
like the only life it's going to change
is mine in a negative way so
so you're at this point in the journey
you've started the youtube channel
you're making like i how how
what sort of ballpark of money were you
making from those pdfs at the time
beyond kind of day one if you're open
sharing well actually to be fair the
reason i ever shared in the beginning
was because people would look at my
house and be like
ah it must be nice having rich parents
my like i come from a very privileged
background and have been open about that
but also at the same time when i've
publicly sold hundreds of thousands of
pdfs for 35 pounds like do the maths you
know like i said like i was kind of just
like
like you have a calculator for free on
your phone yeah it's like it's not that
hard to like i will be the first to say
that all of these other things helped me
yeah and being like white and like
pretty privileged and all of the like
slim and able-bodied and all of these
things of course they're going to help
and of course like my background as well
will hugely happen i'll be the first to
say that but when you also add up
literally what happened from when i
wrote something paid my friend 50 quid
to put it into a pdf built a shopify
site and put it on sale you can also do
that maths so
ballpark figure i think that we
sold
in total
around 300 000
300 to 350 000 of those
pdfs bloody hell
yes incredible so that was whether that
always has been where the like bulk of
my income came from and then i
invested that money into
the businesses that i then started
damn just a quick break from the podcast
to introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly short form now short form is
the single best service that summarizes
books that i have ever used i've used
them all in short form is by far the
best one because it's not just a book
summary service what they have is that
they have summaries of books where they
have like a one pager and then they have
like a detailed chapter by chapter
outline but it's great because in
particular if the author like let's say
simon sonic start with why they've got a
sexual from summary of that book which
is what i read when i was revisiting the
ideas from the book so it's great for
that um but if there's an idea that the
author says which another author or
another source disagrees with they put a
little short form note and so they say
hey this idea that simon sonic talks
about is controversial because
and it just helps you get a way more
holistic understanding of what's
actually going on with the book that
you're reading so that you don't
necessarily take the author's opinion at
face value for me personally i use short
form firstly if i'm thinking of reading
a book but i don't want i don't
necessarily want to read the whole book
in its entirety in the first instance i
will often read the short form summary
if they have it and they usually do and
if i vibe with the summary then i think
okay now it's worth reading the actual
book or alternatively if i've read a
book in the past or whatever and i want
to revisit the ideas from that firstly i
look at my kindle highlight and then i
look at the short form summary and it
really helps when i'm creating content
around like book summaries and stuff on
my website for my youtube channel so
short form is great if you want to check
it out then head over to shortform.com
forward slash deep dive or hit the link
in the video description and that will
give you 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much short
form for sponsoring this episode what
was the best thing and what was the
worst thing about suddenly making stupid
amounts of money while you're at uni
best thing was that i suddenly had a
lot of freedom
i
did not obviously worry about money at
all i
was able to do amazing things with my
friends it's just like these fun things
i
it's not like i was like i've never been
on a private jet i've never you know
like all of it it's not like i was
renting yachts and stuff that freedom
100
one of the biggest benefits i was able
to like rent a flat in the holidays
rather than
moving home because where i was at home
it wasn't an environment that i could
like film in and all of these all of
these very different things but i
wouldn't yeah that was kind of like the
parameters but at the same time i was
still at uni i was still doing the same
things it couldn't buy me good grades
you know all of that so i think that
really
for the three years that i first three
years that i was learning that i really
i was also the same as
other than the huge amount of money i
was making i was also kind of
still doing the same thing yeah
yeah it didn't kind of like change
everything all in one i'd say the worst
part about it i don't i don't think i
could possibly say that there was an
awful part about it other than
probably working harder and harder and
harder because i suddenly had this
infinite ability to
essentially at one stage almost felt
like print money by just working harder
like doing more content yeah
being more inventive
looking more at stats
hiring more people starting businesses
like all of this that was the multiplier
effect of doing any of those things was
just so huge that i just
i did not stop at any time i just yeah
balls to the walls
yeah i think it's one of the so so for
me the
the kind of passive income journey was
less stark but it's like from my second
year i started a business tutoring kids
to get into medical school and from that
point you know that year i made like 10k
and i was like oh my god yeah don't
worry about the price of a meal at a
restaurant and the next year was like
40k and i'm like bloody hell i'm making
as much as a junior is and i'm in my
third year of med school and then it
sort of like escalated very slowly until
the youtube thing started but like that
was a few years later yeah so i had that
sort of experience of the sort of the
the middle ground um but even even even
then i i remember there were there were
times where i was almost doing an roi
calculation of like okay i want to watch
an episode of the vampire diary that's
an hour i could be spending marking
these freaking beemat essays and like if
it's for 20
and all these kind of things where that
then started to filter into my life yeah
and i wouldn't change that for the world
i'm not saying like oh my god yeah i
wouldn't want to have started the
businesses or the youtube channel or
anything but it does sort of change your
relationship with time in a weird way
yeah and i think pre-making money if i
had if i'd known what my future would
look like i would have said oh of course
once you're making above i don't know
50k a year at that point it's enough and
you don't need to make any more money
yeah but then as the numbers go up then
it's like oh but then the desire to make
even more money keeps them going up
for me
no no i completely agree with that i
also would say that i'm very much i'm a
planner and i was very aware of the fact
that what i was doing was probably in a
golden age at a golden time with a
golden product like i literally struck
gold and so my
what i then did obviously to create
longevity was invest those into separate
businesses that have built themselves
beyond that
but
so i would say that even at that stage
when you know i'd say
i'd go to the library from
eight nine to five six come home film
videos slash edit videos and then the
whole of one day a week i just do back
to back filming like whatever it would
be like a get ready with me a q a like
any of those things just like back to
back and as you say it was uncapped it
was it well it was literally only capped
by my time and then the more i put into
it the multiplier effect for how much
time i was spending on it was just so
much bigger all of these things i would
say that i
was also really conscious of the fact
that it's not a career with a lot of
longevity
and i
wanted to
set myself up for my future and i'm an
anxious person
and
creating
that was at the i would say from the
instant i started that i'd say it
probably took a month until i was like
right how do i make sure this lasts and
sets me up for my future so that if this
comes crashing and burn like comes down
one day i have investments and a
business and all of these things yeah
this is the
the thing that i think about a lot as
well like the the career of uh an online
influencer or whatever you want to call
it
i think it's so interesting it's almost
like being an athlete where you know you
have yeah a small amount of time in the
limelight to make all the hay while the
sun shines well even like say even my
financial advisor is
covers those both those areas it's like
media sport and it's those particular
things because you know you have a
maximum
10-year career window and that's a huge
privilege in certain ways because if you
can make enough money in 10 years to set
you up for the rest of your life you are
leaps and bounds like luckier than the
rest of the population but also
it i was really clear on that from the
beginning and i also think that because
in my head success had previously been
like being a lawyer or working in an
investment bank or any of these things
i had this real
kind of
knowledge of or like worry of the fact
that i was really successful
at that point in time and there was
going to be a point 15 years later
around that people are
making partner at their law firm and
like doing all of these things and if i
have
[ __ ] it by that stage then i'm gonna
be like oh [ __ ]
so um yeah i was really conscious of
that it's interesting that well like
what your timeline was for this because
and i'm not sure how sort of plugged in
you are to the sort of creator economy
these days but the conversations that i
have with
anyone so from 500k to like 10 million
subscribers is this level of like okay
cool i'm succeeding as an individual but
i need to figure out how to diversify
and try and build a business and a brand
that's separate from me so that it
doesn't rely on me showing up being like
what's up guys every single day to the
campus yeah yeah cause that is an
unsustainable way of living yeah of
course and and in a way it's like the i
think the arc is people start off with a
job or being students where they
basically have very little autonomy to
then becoming creators where they're
like oh autonomy but then you become a
creator like oh actually i am kind of a
slave to the algorithm i have to keep a
slave to consistency in a way a slave to
the audience i might say and therefore
then the kind of the golden end bit is
the thing that you did ages ago before
it was cool which is yeah set up
separate businesses which can then
theoretically run without you hire a
team
and build those brands as their own
thing
so
like were there examples of people doing
that or did you just kind of know that
okay this this is obviously the next
step
i think i knew
about
a year into making
no probably a year and a half to two
years into making
quite a lot of money i think i knew
that i
loved making the money like completely
transparent of course i did
but
it wasn't with each marginal
breakthrough in how much money i was
making it wasn't bringing me marginal
happiness
in fact i think it was a career that was
entirely incompatible
with
my personality in some ways or like the
reward systems like in my head so
although it was a career that was
compatible in terms of my personality in
the way that you know thankfully people
seem to like my content
i
it was incompatible in the way that as
i've said like i'm a people pleaser i
don't want to have to care about what
people think in order to make my money i
think that was one of the really big
things and also i have other passions
and
this
like what i loved doing was the like
really assessing the algorithm
strategically working out what types of
content i should be doing looking at
what types of you know every time i'd
work on a brand with a brand deal i'd be
like you should really make this i was
like people would absolutely love this
and i'd be
trying to go above and beyond say like i
was working with
say now i'm obviously have an active boy
company um so i was working with an
active fire company at the time it'd be
like you should really make these
leggings because like these ones just
like fall down in this way and like
people really want it to be like this
and feel like this and you should try
this type of marketing instead because
like actually people in my audience
people who are my age really want to see
you know more body types or more like
diverse models or you know any of these
things and i'd really be trying to kind
of like backseat drive in that way and
that wasn't my role my role was sitting
there and like wearing the stuff and
looking nice and all of that and i was
like this doesn't bring me fulfillment
on a daily basis what does bring me
fulfillment is you know doing the
strategy and it working but that like
working on it was probably the happiest
i felt versus like
you know i was doing really well and it
wasn't necessarily that was making me
any happier and so i think i noticed
probably luckily quite early on because
i think what we're seeing at the moment
is this kind of like second phase of
like creator economy where we're seeing
people
we're seeing the ends of lots of
people's careers and we're seeing them
pivot at that stage to creating a
business but actually ultimately you
need more influence to have a business
and to sell things than you do to do
brand deals
like you because you've got to put cash
down you've got to
have staff you've got to like all of
these things you actually need more sway
and so it i don't think it hugely works
as an end of career thing unless you're
starting it with some real business
acumen that you're not using yourself as
the marketing budget and you're going to
do that all separately because obviously
anyone can start up a business but i
think that because
and because i had the freedom to do so
because it wasn't that
well i was
making an obscene amount i was kind of
making an obscene amount of money and i
didn't need to you know there was i
could i could slow down at paces and it
wouldn't slow down and all of that and i
just kind of realized that the most joy
i ever got was talking to the bra either
like strongly collaborating with things
in terms of their actual product like
the actual marketing like the strategy
in terms of like my types of audience
exactly how to reach them exactly what
they care about like all of these things
that was what i enjoyed and doing that
for my first business ready which was
what started five and a half years ago
now and then setting up my second
business tala which was set up it would
have been like four and a half years ago
now but actually
launched three and a half years ago was
like that was where i got like joy and
now i'm sitting in an office five days a
week
making far less money than i ever made
before because as in you know because
it's all for the long term like it's all
in the businesses it's all to hopefully
you know create something amazing
and that makes me
a lot less yep
but it makes me far happier and i'm sure
in the long term you know it will have
its rewards it's like the value of a
company is different but yeah i think i
think this is one of those things that
people don't often talk about with the
creator stuff which is that
if you look at different creators like
they become successful like doing the
thing like whatever it is instagram
youtube tick tock et cetera et cetera
but for different people there's
different parts of the thing that are
particularly fun like for me my thing of
like i often think
if i won the lottery if i decided that
i'm not allowed if someone said that you
weren't allowed to make a penny anymore
in your life
what would i do with my time
it would mostly be probably continuing
to make educational youtube videos
because i just love teaching yeah and
that was my jam and i couldn't really
care less about the editing side of
things and i couldn't really care less
about brand deals no offense to
whoever's sponsoring this episode but
the thing that i vibe with is just like
oh let's take this complicated thing
let's read a paper let's break it down
into like a little diagram sorted
similarly we've got friends who just
freaking love the editing the creative
craft it sounds like view is like the
business side of things the
entrepreneurialism the marketing the
branding that yeah just finding out
exactly what would resonate with my
audience that week and like
why and why that exact you know if i was
working
with a company
why that thing was just like slightly or
like which areas of that product to
really lean on because i knew it would
speak to my audience or which to steer
away from or which to you know talk to
the company about maybe considering
doing and i had so little they were like
yeah cool
do your video like as in that that and
that you know for me i was
lucky enough to be in the position that
actually i could
not put out any content for
you know a good few years now it's
really been and at that stage had a made
enough for myself to set myself up to be
fine and also to set my businesses up to
be fine and to
actually do what i love every day which
is i believe it or not working in an
office
back to the back to the og job js
peak influencer career you're making
stupid amounts of money on the internet
what was it that changed and like what
was the sort of the winding down of the
influencer brand so i think it all i
knew i'd wanted to do it for a while
just again exact same thing i knew i
wanted to move more towards creating
brands and working on like
the the back end side rather than the
creating content i also think that
i i think it's i mean i didn't know that
this was going to happen but i think in
part that what's been amazing for me as
part of this is like the creator economy
now is focused on amazing content and i
never made amazing content like i never
made content that was really high-end or
that was really succinct or that was any
of like
i would spend a lot of time on why i was
i did that for a reason i don't you know
i don't think my audience wanted polish
content but actually now on the
algorithms
like god knows how i would have fed and
i think that
you know i i got to that stage and i'd
also started moving i started setting up
tala kind of behind the scenes
and that was what i was i was so and
still am so so so passionate about that
because to me
that was what the industry needed and
i'd worked in this fitness activewear
industry for a few years at that point
and that was like what was needed and so
i was so excited about that because like
concept even if i was studying it
completely unrelated to
myself as an influence or any of those
things was so exciting and i think i
just got so much more excited by that
that i was like ah
maybe it's time to like
say you know this has been amazing yeah
and kind of you know cut myself off from
that income in a way and just pivot into
something else i was also coming up to
when i launched tala
it was the month before my finals i was
i'd already said at that stage like guys
just fyi i'm not gonna be creating as
much content i'm doing my finals i did a
bit of content i still did probably like
one youtube video a week which is insane
but usually i'd been doing three a week
and then i just never really went back
i never really went back i moved back to
i moved to london
and
i
was so in love with growing tala and
shreddy
that i was just like
no one expects anyone to make their full
career choice and stick to it at 18
which is when i made mine
no one would be surprised if someone
worked for something throughout their
time at uni and worked to something else
from when they graduated
that's literally exactly what i did it
just happened that mine was
relatively more high profile obviously
that comes with a pivot that
you know
obviously some people aren't going to
understand but ultimately at the end of
the day i think i really prioritized
that for a long time because of online
opinion and also because of how much
money it was making me
and got to a point where i was like well
is the end goal money or is the end goal
happiness and fulfillment and ultimately
ideally i'd have both
but ultimately if you're getting if
you're in that point of privilege that
you're getting more money
that you'd assume would lead to more
happiness rather than just getting a
roof over your head then if that is not
getting your happiness then then pivoted
pivoting seemed the right thing to do so
i kind of did it quite abruptly and
never really went back i mean i tried to
put i tried to do some consistent things
that put out good content that are
almost to
thank the really loyal people who've
stuck around and watch my journey and
supported my journey for a long time
i assume that most of
my following is actually from back then
and actually the large majority of
people i meet now are like oh i didn't
know you did youtube and i'm like really
yeah so i think it's more just like
crossed over in the past three and a
half years really or three years
probably since i've created a lot of
content that following has just like
lots of people will have left and lots
of people will have joined lots of
people from the fitness side and uni
side would have left and lots of people
from the like business and work and like
all of that will have joined and so it's
been quite a nice pivot hey friends hope
you're enjoying the podcast so far uh
just interrupting the podcast episode to
give you a little message from our
sponsor which happens to be shopify
shopify is freaking incredible it is the
world's best all-in-one platform for
managing any kind of e-commerce store
and it's just fantastic for anyone who
wants to start and grow and manage an
online business shopify is great because
it lets you sell in person and also
online and also across all the major
social platforms and actually we've been
personally using shopify for over a year
to sell our merch line the part-time
productivity line of essentially which
is the stationary brand that i've built
up over the last year and shopify is
amazing and integrating with like
basically every service provider we
could want and really taking all of the
hassle out of managing logistics and
customer support and accepting online
payments and all of that stuff very
excitingly shopify has just partnered
with youtube so now you can connect your
shopify store to your youtube channel
and so what we are in the process of
doing is connecting our shopify store on
shop.live.com uh over to the youtube
channel so that people will be able to
buy products directly from the youtube
channel for alia dal and for the other
vlogs channel and for the deep dive
podcast youtube channel that's gonna be
sick and we're super excited about that
if any of that sounds good and you also
want to start or grow or manage your
online business with shopify then head
over to shopify.com forward slash ali
abdul and that link will take you to a
page that has all the information you
need to know about shopify and how you
can use it to potentially start and grow
your own online business so thank you so
much shopify for sponsoring this episode
it's not unusual for people to make
career changes you know i went out of
medicine and to become a youtuber but if
i was making 10 times as much money
during my doing medicine as i would have
done through youtube
that at that point people start with and
and especially
to the like externally it sort of looks
like my god you're living the dream you
can literally push whatever you want
you're making stupid amounts of money
like why would you
want to take a hit on all those fronts
so you can post whatever you want yes
but if you don't want to post no
so it's like it's not a it's a it's a
whole change rather than a like i now
don't you know you're lucky if you get a
[ __ ] mirror selfie from me like that
that's kind of the reality unfortunately
my poor manager cries every day i will
not do a reel but i
um i think the thing is is because
actually
yes i could post everything i want and i
can make a huge amount of money and i
understand that's a hugely privileged
position to be in and actually
the one thing i couldn't do within that
is stop posting and disappear or i could
just then live off the book but
ultimately the idea was that to pivot
that into something where i could stop
posting and still make money and i also
think that everyone knows there's a
threshold above that point you're not
going to be any more happy by earning
any more money i was burning millions a
year and i just it wasn't like
of course it was amazing but it wasn't
necessarily the marginal happiness
between that wasn't there so i'd been
lucky to be able to have a position as
well
that i've changed into that has also
you know i'm not going to say now that i
don't make a lot of money i do but it's
it's a very different
it's very different the the work
proportion to the money proportion very
different and also the amount but um i'm
also a lot happier and more fulfilled
and i use my brain on a daily basis
which
was not compatible with
halls yeah
yeah i guess this is a this is a place
where i guess in the in the business
world everyone gets to
eventually like within the context of
running a business where let's say
you've got multiple projects on the go
and you know that actually this one is
really profitable but actually it's not
contributing to the wider goal of the
business it's not contributing to the
happiness of you or the team
and it's a big decision to shut down the
project but usually when people do it
they're like breath of fresh air best
thing i ever did did you have that kind
of approach that when you decided to
abruptly wind down the influencer career
one of my biggest mottos that i think in
business and in life
that i do not listen to but absolutely
try to every day is do less better
and
i think that that really really had an
impact at that stage i could and also
the most lucrative option would have
been to continue posting as i was while
doing this pivot that would have been a
lot safer a lot less risky um would have
made a lot of people kind of probably
stay and follow the journey but i
literally had enough like i was actually
like this is not what i want to do and i
want to change my career and i'm lucky
enough to be in the position where i can
and i have the freedom to and i have the
money too all of that there was i think
probably like a month or so into because
it wasn't necessarily a conscious cut
off point it more being that i'd wound
down the content because of something
else and then there was a few months in
that i was like
i'm not going back to this like i i'd
paid
you know deposits on
content that i was doing with
videographers i'd you know obviously
didn't like ask for any of that back but
it was it was like there was stuff a
huge amount of stuff planned a huge
amount of work gone into a lot of things
and i just
um
what was that
i definitely want to dig into the
logistics of running a
physical goods business yes but like i
wonder if we can start with shreddy yes
what was the kind of origin story for
shreddy and why not just keep selling
pdfs
yeah
so why not keep selling pdfs we
continued selling pdfs for
a good bit of time after we pivoted to
an app and pivoted to physical products
so timeline was pdfs nine months later
first physical products a year and a
half later app okay so
and the pdfs only went a few months
after
the
app was launched so they're still like
keeping security it's not good to jump
ship all the time but i think what's
really really really important is
evolution and i think that
what's very very true is the industry
and things like pdfs aren't
you know the industry's moved on like in
this it doesn't work as a business model
in the way that people can airdrop them
now they can screenshot them and send
them like all of these things whereas
with an app you're getting a service um
and so it's a subscription service and a
subscription business model as well it's
a lot easier to run
so the
pivot for that was slow i think that
people think with businesses you know
they'll be the way
you come up with some big concept and it
works the concept
you know came about after the business
even existed and grew basically came
about after the business existed well
because the business started as these
pdfs so like
workout guides essentially that people
would all do together i guess that's the
loose concept but it's not like a big
you know find your why type golden
circle idea that's like going to change
the world right
it's talking to these same audience
you're going to go for it's essentially
a minimum viable product
it helps you learn a lot of things um we
try we've tried products that don't work
we've tried you know
and all all it's about is trying things
and doing more of what does work and
less of what doesn't work but so the
concept then came about that was the
when people would talk about the guides
the pdf guides they'd say like oh i just
love this because i've never trained
this way
and i
thought that i had to hate working out
okay and i really liked this and it was
you know it was probably the beginning
of the time that lifting was even
lifting weights was even kind of con
encouraged started to be encouraged for
women it was right at the beginning of
that and so it was lifting weights but
it was in quite a high intensity way so
women who were used to wanting to sweat
during their workouts quite a lot
were doing that through lifting and that
was like the type of training and then
people would ask me they'd be like oh
well i like to do hit workouts so i
can't stick to the guide i'd be like
well don't do that like genuinely don't
buy the guide like this isn't for you um
and then people will be like well i like
running and then people would be like
well i like working out from home
working out from home is a huge thing
now it wasn't at the time i'm not saying
that that was us that made it but it was
just like the industry was different and
so the concept for shredi the app came
about
half based on the fact that the pdf
model we kind of foresaw in probably a
year or so was gonna completely die out
based on it being completely shareable
it's
being quite expensive versus what people
are paying for subscriptions it being
completely static you can't update it
that easily and if you do people expect
the new version rather than buying
another one all of these various
different things so as part of the
business model that we knew we needed to
evolve and the other part of it was we
thought we could add a huge amount more
value so the concept behind shreddy was
that we don't believe you should do
workouts you hate to get results you
love so it's all about putting in all
your preferences how long you like to
work out a day home or gym what type of
just do you want yoga in there too do
you want hip workouts do you want
strength workouts do you want body
weight like all of these things putting
in all of your preferences and then it
creates you your and your goals as well
because that's really important and then
it creates your perfect workout plan
based on your preferences with your
goals in mind because the whole idea is
that actually you're never going to
stick to something you hate you might
stick to it for eight weeks but you're
not going to have any lasting change so
the whole idea of shredding has always
been around
getting people
an action plan that matches their
preferences and again over time as soon
as you know we were able to set it up on
the app
having a team of personal trainers
nutritionists trainers on the app all of
these things
those people are far better at that job
than i am
and if sheree was ever going to be kind
of beyond me
and reach its full potential even in
terms of personal training in terms of
nutrition in terms of any of these
things it was not going to be me
i couldn't run the business but what i
can't do you know the business potential
was kept at myself and people who want
to do my types of workouts and people
who
you know just all of that and there was
so much more potential that we could
apply it to and so that's
what we did
who's we back in the day
so initially so my first ever pdfs i did
completely on my own so i built the
shopify site on a theme
put a digital plug-in and all of that
that i said before and then when i was
right before i was releasing the guide
so i'd written the guides i'd plan to
sell it on my the website that i'd
already set up for the pdfs the year
before and then i'd been approached by a
company that was just starting up at the
time and they said like hey we can do it
for you and we'll do all your customer
service just for a profit split and i
was like oh i don't need customer
service i
like it's a digital download the worst
that can happen is someone either
doesn't like it doesn't think they've
got what they want or never got the
thing i can deal with those and so i was
quite resistant and they came back and
they were like hey we're really
we're starting up our business working
with influencers and we can do your
customer service and we also have an app
we can put we can upload these onto an
app so people can have a laptop
functionality and i was like that's
you know that's enticing and they were
like also this is going to sell a lot
more than your original pdfs and you
will need customer service that you
should not be doing that and so
i
at that stage i basically
they they
paid me a sign-on bonus they were
starting up at the time and obviously it
was going to get some traction
so i signed on with them
did obviously better than we ever would
have expected so they ran they built me
a new site they ran the customer service
and from then onwards i was partnering
with them for manufacturing the
conceptualization of the business moving
forward and also building a team within
that infrastructure to run what shreddy
has become oh that's interesting yeah i
guess
how how popular are those sorts of
companies these like are there lots of
people doing that yeah that's i i
haven't really explored from well
i mean it's essentially it's essentially
like licensing providers so that happens
hugely within the influencer marketing
industry so if you think of like any
influencer can set up a brand and is
unlikely to be an expert in setting up a
brand or talking to suppliers or any of
these things but
has a huge amount of selling power so if
you plug in all of those other things
and do it for in exchange for a
percentage of the revenue then great
it's slightly different the way we
work together because we both kind of
started at the same time so we've worked
as a licensing provider in a lot of ways
but we've also built a shredi team
together so essentially
the company that's been built um
is it's it's not kind of a yeah there's
lots of like turnkey influencer
solutions and they're incredible it's so
smart if you think about it if you think
of like your favorite fashion blogger
and they want to set up a line
they're if they're being paid 5 000
pounds for an instagram post
is it worth their time to spend three
days a week on the phone with suppliers
tweaking designs all of these things no
it's not it's actually much better for
them to have someone doing all of these
different things it's it's building a
team 101 it's building a business 101
and there are people who can plug that
in and people who can do the creative
direction the marketing the all of that
which is the influencer
yeah cause we've been kind of toying
with the idea that oh it would be cool
to maybe make a productivity app but
i've heard it's like oh it cost like
100k plus yeah or it would be cool i
really like the idea of making my own
like mechanical keyboard yeah probably
sick or like a laptop bag because i
think i'd use it and it would sell
because the audience i'll put you in
touch that'll be amazing yeah yeah
i didn't know these sorts of companies
they exist and there's so many different
types of them as well i think there's a
lot of
it's a very hot industry so there's
lots of
lots of good and lots of
i'd say some sharkiness because there's
so much money in it but i'd say there's
some really really great people and it
makes a lot of sense in the same way as
like if
you know ed sheeran wants to make some
amazing merch or some a tracksuit line
or whatever it's ed sheeran it does not
make sen and actually it would be a bad
decision on his front to be the person
on the phone to the suppliers so it's
actually really smart from the
influencer as well to be able to do that
and
yeah a hundred percent there are so many
people in the industry and that's how a
lot of influence of businesses have
started
so shreddie
has a team
with them essentially okay um so we've
built the team so we have you know
normal roles it's we've got
you know crm managers and employers
marketing managers and all of those
things that kind of sit entirely in a
shreddy team but the manufacturing side
is backed up from that side and tala is
standalone was actually original like
had a licensing partnership at one point
and all is in-house
now all is in-house is in
physically like like ownership
manufacturers like we have our own
entire product team manufacturing like
all of that and is that also in
partnership with this other company no
no no no that's that's like
i think that's yeah that's completely
standalone
tyler is its own entity so for shreddie
you partnered up with this company
you've sort of built it together over
time yeah and then you were like cool i
want to do my own thing like what was
the so origin story there so shreddy
i i'm still the solo founder so i
founded it yeah because it kind of
started before that point but the team
has been built up with these amazing
people who do their job far better
especially at the time when i was at
university there was no you know if i
wanted to suddenly start manufacturing
resistance bands in the same way as you
you'd probably build in bring in like a
cto if you wanted to build an app it was
essentially that so
the difference was that they can
you know often say like it completely
depends from model to model but say if
i'm like oh we could potentially do this
product usually you'd have to invest 20
000 pounds into buying the stock for
example and if you can guarantee that
you're likely going to sell it then
there are like
there's also even arrangements that you
can make that someone can essentially
put the cash flow because you know it's
going to sell so that's a really
important part of the model with tala it
made sense at essentially based on the
business i wanted to build it made sense
for it to be completely standalone
and
that's a well i started it as a solo
founder i'd partnered with some
factories and factory partners to
essentially make the amazing product and
the whole idea of creating seamless act
seamless sustainable activewear
at a price point that was competitive
with non-sustainable act where everyone
was like no way like [ __ ] off like you
can't do that and was lucky to have
amazing partners who had the
manufacturing facilities who wanted to
make that happen so we spent a year
trying to essentially make that happen
and launching from that the way the
business
wanted to or the way i wanted the
business to grow beyond that in terms of
like really maintaining its ethics
really maintaining all the all the kind
of
points that i believe are essential to
tala's growth also moving away from me
all of these things made sense to kind
of have everything in house and now it's
been built up to a team where every
department is essentially completely
in-house we'll use you know a paid
search agency and you know all of these
different things that are third party
but everything the whole team is
in-house so you were doing this so were
you on the phone with factories when you
were at university
or like what did that look like yeah no
so it's a very good question so this is
why i would so
say for shreddy when we did our first
ever physical product which were
resistance bands at the time this would
be partnering with amazing people who
know far better than me in terms of like
suppliers we'd be like oh we should make
this product and
that kind of partnership was essentially
like they would be able to go okay in
the same way as if you hired a head of a
head of production for example or a head
of merchandising they'd go out and like
find the stuff you get the product you
you know your buyer would look at it and
you'd like work out and so they were
doing a lot of that i had a lot of
conversations with a lot of factories
for a lot of different products so for
i did
notebooks at one stage did with tala to
i cannot tell you how many different
people we spoke to and
so kind of depends on the product
depends on the time okay
let's say someone listening to this
decides that they also want to start an
activewear brand right yes
what are the steps involved in
figuring this out how much of a faff is
it is it like how easy is it to get a
business like this off the ground if you
were doing it today it is a huge faff
right an enormous faff you also have to
have
money to put into it it's definitely not
like uh it was very different with the
you know the pdfs for example where they
you didn't need a lot of there weren't a
lot of like sunk cost or marginal cost
to be making the product so you were
able to kind of make the money
essentially straight up and then put
that into things like we did with the
app say
for clothing obviously you need to be
able to foot the even just buying the
stock but even before then paying for
samples like
sometime it depends if you have no like
credit history or your business doesn't
have any credit history usually say you
pay for stock it will completely depend
on your payment terms but some of them
you'll have to pay 50 up front and then
50
30 days after it's exited the factory or
something it completely depends but
actually when you're at the beginning of
your journey if you don't have a lot to
prove you'll probably be able to do that
the way most people start will be then
either if they have cash of their own or
you know getting a loan or whatever it
might be there are loads of trade shows
you can go to in terms of finding the
right fabrics in terms of finding the
fits and all of this i had an absolute
baptism of fire because i thought things
like
okay you think that making a t-shirt is
going to be pretty yeah self-explanatory
just google it right yeah like just like
i'll make a t-shirt there was this for
our first collection i really just
wanted like an oversized black t-shirt
as part of the collection but i wanted
like some detailing on it
we ended up having to scrap
no we had the t-shirt for i think it was
like the second launch or the first
restock the second launch
this t-shirt every time it would come
from the factory it would like this one
time it came and like the whole body was
tight and then the arms were like this
like oversized t-shirt like
enormous sleeves whereas like the rest
of it would be tight like everything is
re like you can send you can send a
t-shirt to someone and be like oh yeah
this is the type of like shape i want
all of this it also like you will learn
over time how much it depends on like
the materials how much it depends on the
factory you're working with in terms of
communication and all of this um but
yeah i had no experience in buying in
which is like the role that people play
at fashion
fashion companies if they're like you
know talking to the supplier getting the
stock all of these various different
things and kind of yeah talking to the
yeah essentially i had absolutely no
experience with that so that wasn't
absolute back to slimmer fire because
i'd like receive this t-shirt and be
like
i just want a t-shirt yeah i just got a
t-shirt but then again some things were
much easier to get so sports bra was
absolutely impossible i just couldn't
understand why every time it came it
looked like a sock it was just like so
bad but then you and that's why it took
so long to launch we kind of
conceptualized the idea for tala in
second end of second year and we didn't
launch until may of third year and there
were just certain things that would come
back and you'd be like
like surely this makes sense but then
i'd say that's one of the biggest things
that is like you'll get these samples
back and you'll be like okay
whereas now the way the business works
is you know every wednesday morning we
have three two three hours of fit
sessions which is essentially like all
the samples that have come from
factories we have a fit model in there
and we go over and do like oh take two
inches off the waist or actually the the
way the wrap is sitting is like skewing
a bit to the left or it's like pulling a
bit in this way so it doesn't look as
high quality like all of these things
that's how you do it now whereas like
back on the day i'd be trying it on and
then i'd be doing the fit comments on
myself i'm also not a fit model in a fit
model is essentially something that's
essentially like a human mannequin okay
so you do everything graded on
particular sizes because
that's like it and you'll do it for each
side so like extra small small medium
large extra large upwards it
is all based on like average proportions
okay so you have higher
there are freelancers who are like i am
an average medium yeah or something so
we yeah exactly so like for example like
yesterday we had a 4xl fit session which
will be someone who's for xl to be
fitting essentially for xl yeah actually
we'll have an excel fit session we'll
have a you know yesterday
morning was it wednesday yeah it was
wednesday yesterday morning we had a
small session that will be like the
software you're fitting on that so it
completely depends but it obviously the
more fit sessions you do with more
different sizes the more accurate you're
going to be and not like in terms of
different sizes but again everyone's
unique so like it's always you always
you know how clothes fit differently on
you but even like i'd be trying them and
i have like nowhere near fit model
proportions and i'd be like no
it has to be like in this much and i
just learnt over time like actually i
can't do things to my proportions we
have to do like this because you can't
base an entire company based on that but
yeah it's it's so complicated in that
actually i had no knowledge of you know
how fashion companies worked tools which
made it an
a lot longer process but i talked to so
many of my friends now who also kind of
like started fashion companies and all
that you just look at like some of the
samples that came back and you're just
like what that like
i thought you wouldn't be able to get a
t-shirt wrong like yeah i was also
probably giving terrible instructions
because i had no experience in fashion
so you're in your third year of uni
you're dealing with all this faf of
trying to start an active wire brand
while also doing the influencery stuff
on the side
a
how did you manage your time that
classic question and b why did you not
like what made you just not give up with
the whole faf of you know i'll screw it
i'll just sell pdfs and continue to make
millions
so i was continuing to sell ps still at
this stage but i think i was really
looking i was like there's a maximum
amount of time more that i'm going to
really want to be doing what i'm doing
now so it was an investment in my future
it was respecting kind of like my future
self and my
i could have said that i could have
still been doing that now and there
would have been a lot of merit in it and
i'm sure i would have made a lot of
money and like all of that but it wasn't
what i wanted to do so all of this was
like this long term in the same way as
you like you'll make a maybe like a
five-year plan now and be like by the
time i'm 27 i want to live by myself or
like i want to you know like all of
these are various different things
so
that was kind of like part of my plan
the reason i started this
even had the original idea for tala was
that i'd been working with activewear
companies for years at this point and as
i said before there would be some really
clear things that i'd be like this is we
should really do this like trust me
people will love this
and obviously it doesn't it doesn't work
that way i was the influencer i was
there to be you know to look nice and
try things on and make content
entertaining and i had personally moved
away from
you know back in the day i very
embarrassingly did like plt halls i did
like lots of stuff with fast fashion it
was was that embarrassing because plt's
like pretty little thing like their
ethics are trash like as in are they oh
yes i saw some of that in the morning
yeah
plt's about company i never heard of
them before but fast fashion in general
like their their ethics are awful like
the amount they're paying their
suppliers the amount you know just like
all of it it's it's killing everything
anyway that was like you know back when
i was doing that that was how i made a
lot of my money i was you know promoting
a lot of fast fashion i think you know
from affiliate links i'd be making tens
of thousands a month and from literally
just linking my outfits and like all of
these things and i
decided to i cut my i remember i cut my
one of my big fast fashion contracts and
was like i actually it it just doesn't
work in my head it's i don't i don't
want to be doing this anymore and i
moved away kind of mostly and i still
wouldn't say that i fully moved away in
terms of like doing exactly what's in
line with what i you know you know that
kind of cognitive dissonance of being
like oh i really shouldn't buy this but
like
you know i wouldn't say i'm perfect in
any way but i generally moved away from
shopping fast fashion for sure and just
to more things that i were kind of more
transparent and i realized about six
months after doing that and cutting all
my fast fashion contracts and any fast
fashion brand deals that i had
just completely left activewear out of
that because it was fitness and you kind
of see it as necessary like you can't
work out in your jeans so you're like
well i need some leggings and it needs
to have certain performance qualities
and all of these things and so i'd
actually just like not looked at it in
the same way and then so i started while
still partnered with you know with
activewear companies and all of this i
started like
googling sustainable activewear
companies there literally was nothing in
the uk first of all but if you think of
sustainable fashion as a whole it's
rental pre-owned sustainable fabrics
that's like i'd say the three ways that
and small business i'd say probably the
four ways you get more sustainable
fashion i think for sustainable fashions
than oxymoron but more sustainable sorry
why sustainable fashion
because fashion as a whole is one of the
most polluting industries in the world
and you know we're not talking about
people who are
putting clothes on their back we're
talking about halls of tons of
pieces that you do we don't need we have
a huge consumerism problem in terms of
like how much fashion we consume so
fashion as a whole based on trends is
always going to be slightly oxymoronic
in the fact that actually
you can i believe that we can do it more
sustainably and we can do it better with
the fabrics we choose our entire
production process the factories we
partner with like all of these different
things
but i don't think you can have fully
sustainable fashion i think that's
really important to acknowledge
but i
those are like the
four pillars of sustainable fashion but
like rental and pre-owned you don't
really want to do with activewear
because you don't want to rent someone
sweaty activewear you don't really want
to there is pretty a pre-owned market
for activewear but like personally i
don't think it's a
full alternative if people are happy
with it great do it but it i would
happily buy a pre-owned bag or some
trainers or some a blazer or whatever
but i wouldn't happily have a pre-owned
sports bra um and then sustainable
fabrics and small business so there
weren't i'd say in general there aren't
as many small businesses within the
activewear space it's not like kind of
like homeware or any of these things
they're still are there but in terms of
like the bigger activewear industry
sustainable fabrics so
looking at businesses that were doing
sustainable fabrics in activewear first
of all there was almost nothing in the
uk and genuinely there is still so
little there are people who use
sustainable fabrics but they don't talk
about the rest of their production
process their packaging their dyeing
processes their sampling processes all
of these things that actually come into
sustainability that's not just using a
recycled fabric otherwise boohoo using a
recircled fabric would be fine or like
considered sustainable i looked into
those and i remember
because my the way i made money
or one of the ways i made money was
partnering with brands i was looking for
sustainable activewear brands that i
could partner with and when i looked
them up i was like oh i can't partner
with these guys the ones who've done
amazing things and we were by no means
the first and they've done incredible
things were like a hundred pounds for a
pair of leggings which i had a student
audience i would never partner with
brands where the you know rrp of
you know
in things were that expensive it
wouldn't work for me i don't think it
would convert for my audience that's not
who i was speaking to so i remember
thinking like oh like i can't partner
with those people so there was either
double the price sustainable activewear
or
non-sustainably made activewear that was
at a price point that my audience would
like and then i was like well why
isn't there a middle ground like why is
there not sustainable activewear at a
price point that's competitive to this
is it because it can't be done is it
because people think because
some people will pay double for
sustainability because it's you know
people expect it they expect to have to
pay more they expect to you know take
that cost somewhere is it because
there's not enough interest like all of
these various different things
it seemed insane though that the
generation that cared so much about
sustainability and
you know conscious production all of
these things
were also say if there's like
sustainability
and like conscious shopping there's
activewear yeah
the thing that joins these two together
the people who care most about both of
these categories
are millennial gen z
i'd say yeah like they were the ones who
pioneered activewear as like a thing
that you wear outside of the gym like
they were the ones who really cared
about sustainability all of these things
it was like a sweet spot in the middle
but no one was doing it and still
no one is really creating sustainable i
would love to find more brands doing
sustainable activewear at a price point
that's competitive and so that was the
whole concept and i got obsessed with
the idea that this would be possible
especially because i had money to put
into it and i also had an audience that
i could if i would persuade a factory to
make me something for a certain amount
and be like i will we will get this much
money from it because i know it will i
know people want this yeah like i really
know people want this so kind of took
the
two and a half years probably that i'd
had working with activeweb brands being
really clear with exactly what products
people liked why they liked them all of
that so entirely like casual expertise
it wasn't you know traditional training
at all and then a passion for probably
like selfishly wanting to be able to
have activewear and promote activewear
which was so inherent to my brand but
wanting to do that at a point that was
both accessible yeah and made better so
it sounds like for this you had that you
know the whole start with why thing
there was a purpose behind this that you
genuinely carry
yeah way that went way beyond posting
workout photos of yourself or whatever
the influencing you think it was and i
guess when you have that that level of
motivational strength behind the thing
it's like easy enough to almost
unsustainably run yourself for a while
to get it off the ground yes yeah 100
and also like if you think at the same
time i also wanted longevity
and i also wanted to work in like brand
building and all of these things i was
applying for jobs i was literally
applying like when i was at in my final
year i applied for
loads of grad rolls because i was like i
don't want to do social media and so i
was willing to be like i made this much
up to this date and then i just i was
willing to genuinely disappear off the
face of the earth i then found something
that enabled me to do both um and have
since kind of done both but take away
the content yeah yeah so it was it was
very much a y moment and very much a
like wow there's some real product
market fit here yeah and you've just
launched a new line yeah as in it's uh
the way it works now is
you know like
most activewear companies you'll see you
know there'll be a new color there'll be
a new line there'll be all of these
things and
we try and be like that's exactly what
we're
doing in terms of like the it's taking a
long time to really work out where we
are within the industry and my pinpoint
that i
you know when we're talking as a team
like what products should we create what
box are we really trying to tick here
the way we do that is really looking at
the fact that like
actually our competitors aren't other
sustainable brands we're not competing
against
you know people that are double the
price that are making or small
businesses that are making these
beautiful you know incredible products
that are probably a lot more expensive
but you know
you should definitely definitely be
supporting them and do amazing things
what we're competing against is people
deciding not to make their next pro
purchase
from xyz yep
activewear brand that i'm not gonna name
um
or like there are lots of them
we want that person to decide to make a
better purchase
so
important as well like as i said the
kind of sustainable fashion oxymoron
thing as well our transparency lies in
the fact that like we want to be really
clear about the fact that we're well
aware we're not the most sustainable
option the most sustainable option
is not consuming
but if you have this world where it's
like fast fashion which still i'd say a
lot of the gen z millennial crossover is
sitting in and deciding to purchase like
even the fact that people don't know why
fast fashion is bad like it or you know
bad blanket word but like yeah what the
negatives of fast fashion are
that's kind of over here most
sustainable not consuming only buying
second hand
buying really amazing like but you know
high technology really like sustainable
things that i'd say only a few brands
are really getting right which would be
like patagonia like a lot of these
things that like if you need to buy buy
and buy from these things there's so
much middle ground that i really think
if we don't address we're basically
saying no
these people can never be better because
if i had had to go from this to this i
would have pretended i didn't care and i
would have stayed here
what we're trying to do is create a
place within the market where actually
you can just decide to make a
better decision
if that better decision is not buying at
all great we will applaud you with it
for that and we also will stick with you
at every part of your sustainability
journey but actually if we can get all
of these people
to try
more sustainably and more consciously
made stuff once
then we can our data shows that they
repeat and that is hopefully showing
that rather than just necessarily like
buying more they're deciding to move
away from this bit by bit because
they're show it because it's actually
showing them that they
don't need
it's there's no different we're not
making them compromise we're not making
them compromise on quality on color on
fit on style on price we're just
like yeah okay these are what the things
we care about this is how we care about
them this is our this is what we're
showing make like
just a little bit just like a little bit
in that direction and we you know
there's always there's going to be
people who are here that we're not the
right brand for there's going to be
people here who are here that haven't
quite been persuaded yet but our job is
to persuade these people to start to
make better decisions that sounds great
i would guess that some people will hate
on you because you're not quite all the
way to patagonia levels oh yeah like
what other like criticism do you get i
go or hate you get up for or does the
brand get like well i think that what's
really
again when anything's black and white
online and are things like say
sustainable fashions so say we've had a
lot of things within the past year that
actually i've kind of been like actually
i don't like this messaging so say we
like there's yeah there's just like so
many things where it's if you say
something that's like black and white
it's going to be perceived in a black
and white way for example saying
sustainably made
versus sustainable
one is a descriptor one is a label
like one is a you've come to a
conclusion sustainable sustainably made
is just describing it okay got it so we
like using made using sustainable
fabrics made using so people can base
their decision based on the reality
rather than a conclusion that we've
stamped on something okay got it and
you're careful to use the descriptor
rather than that exactly moral judgment
and there'll be so many times when we
make a mistake or we're not really clear
on that messaging or we'll say like
shop with a sustainable brand versus and
then someone will say actually there's
no such thing as sustainable fashion
we'll be like you know what we
completely agree what we are saying that
you ca you can't refute the fact that
this is made from 95
recycled plastic bottles or like any of
these things what you can refute is
whether you should buy it anyway or say
like
use it so say activewear a lot of it has
to be made from synthetic fibers which
versus plant-based fibers are still
going to take a long time to decompose
whereas if they're made from 96 recycled
synthetic fibers that stuff was going to
go to landfill anyway so we'd rather
make it into something that has a new
life of course there's still problems
with that synthetic fabric but
if the plant-based fabric we could have
as a substitute would only last you half
a year
that's not sustainable either and also
you're not going to continue buying that
because you're going to be like well i'm
going to have that for six months so
it's it's a very complex and
nuanced industry and i would say that's
probably one of the big reasons as well
that a influencers don't talk about
sustainability because as soon as you do
you're going to get an absolute [ __ ]
show piled at you and because we as
humans are constantly hypocritical in
what we do in our cognitive dissonance
and we think some ways and we act other
ways and all of this that's a reality
and post a girl for that i think that
there's like
the whole industry the reason why people
you know the reason why a big activewear
brand if there's so much opportunity in
sustainable activewear why wouldn't they
go there because people are still buying
it and like because people are still
happy to buy that and yet if you're a
sustainable brand or a more sustainable
brand and you're talking about those
decisions you're always going to be
slightly oxymoronic and people don't
like that contradiction oh okay and so
it's going to be easier to criticize
whereas actually at the same time you're
criticizing that whilst also wearing
x fast fashion brand so it's like people
don't like the fact that something isn't
easily describable and i'd say fast
fashion sustainable fashion isn't easily
describable because you have to have
like asterix asterix asterix
draw your own conclusions like all of
these things what we can do is be as
transparent as possible and also be as
vocal as possible on what we
think and what we don't think and all of
these things to try and help people make
their own decisions but i also think
that there was you know when i first
started up the business for example
i i probably like there there's so much
like change in some of the ways we like
talk about things and all of these
things in the same way as any single
business but i think it takes refined
messaging over time
and i think that i'm really really happy
with where it is now in the way that the
business is so
it's based on creating activewear that
you can feel good and good about it's
based on creating sustainable activewear
that's at a competitive price point
whether that's for you or not
completely up to you there are things
i'm sure we can always do better there
are things that we
have you know do amazingly well and lots
of them i would say but you know it's a
journey and if i wanted if i'd
like the easier route would have been
not saying anything to do with
sustainability at any point because
people
love a fashion brand the second it's a
fashion brand that ties itself to
something there are stakes
there's also benefits but there are i'd
say there are much higher stakes we get
a lot more
yeah it is just
it's it doesn't fit into a box and that
is that's really hard but we're figuring
out every day and i'm more intent on
disrupting the industry with a more
sustainable solution
than i am on
avoiding negative comments on stuff yeah
like it's natural yeah like it's it's
gonna happen and i'm
constantly so excited by the concept of
tyler and i can't wait to see you know
how and where it
like goes and i think that that's
you know
that fulfills me we have an amazing team
that are super excited all the time and
works so hard because they believe in it
too and
i kind of hope that shows i'd have to
talk about some book stuff working hard
hardly working uh there's a few a few
things in here which i found super
interesting that i'd love to get your
take on and
the the first one was kind of very early
on in in a way when when i saw the title
my editor penguin actually sent me an
advanced copy of it i think i did a
thing for it or something and i kind of
i saw the title i thought it was going
to be like uh oh here's how you can work
hard while also
being a child that kind of vibe and then
i i read the book i was like oh okay
it's like this
contrast but also not this contrast
between productivity and self-care
kind of so i would love to hear your
take on on that i know you can really
write a whole book about it but yeah
what are your
what are your current thoughts on
productivity versus self-care and that
theoretical dividing line between the
two so i began to write the book right
at the beginning of the pandemic because
there was kind of the stage where there
were these two big different kind of
parties online yeah one was like team
productivity and one was like team
self-care yeah and the team productivity
one was like hustle 24 hours like sleep
when you're dead like all of these
things are like big lines in the
background of like a big graphic being
like
yeah that kind of like sleep well you're
dead all of those types of things and
and it was just like hustle hustle
hustle like side hustle culture like
forex traders like you can make all of
this money but also like a more subtle
version of that which was like very like
girl boss culture like a lot of this
stuff which i would have benefited huge
hugely from and then there was this
other side which was like
self-care and that was like no
like do what you need to do cancel that
job that you've got for your well-being
like
quit your job go into something you love
like take a bath put on a candle like
well-being
and then it was like there was like
nothing in between so like if i post
something being like oh one of my big
productivity tips is x
i'd get like an influx of like it's a
like pandemic not a productivity contest
and like how dare you say i should watch
a ted talk at lunch like i should be out
in the park and it's like yeah great
like if that works for you at the same
time i post something being like i
decided not to work late today and to do
this instead
and like the productivity people would
be like well like you can do that
because of x y and z and actually we all
need to do this and like all of that and
there was like there's no like middle
ground and actually there was there's no
acknowledgement of the fact that
actually we all need productivity
and we all need
self-care and that was the kind of like
working hard hardly working thing the
book split into working hard which is
filled with productivity tips a lot of
talk about the
you know generational kind of like
passion paradoxes and like all of these
things managing your time
defining success goal setting like all
of these things a lot very much like
within this kind of like social media
world and then the the hardly working
side is is kind of essentially the
complete opposite but the whole idea is
to create a productivity blueprint that
doesn't completely negate the idea that
we actually need rest or relaxation or
sleep and i think that a lot of
productivity books and a lot of books
have done really well in the kind of
like self-help but
businessy worky improve your life way
are types of books that you can like
stick to for you get really inspired by
and stick to for about two weeks after
and then you're like you completely burn
out because it's not sustainable because
it's not based on the fact that actually
we're all human as well and then on the
opposite side there's like all of these
well-being books that are like do this
and do this and do this and then after
two weeks you're like well now i've lost
my job so it's like there was there was
none of this middle ground and the whole
idea was to create a productivity
blueprint for this generation that
actually acknowledged the
reality of social media the 24-hour news
cycle the
even things like house prices the fact
that we actually have to work for x
amount of time to be able to do x the
fact that we can do whatever online the
fact that we are bombarded with all
types of success whether it's like a
friend from school's marriage or
someone's promotion or
you know like a baby or like any of
these things we're bombarded with those
things all the time so it's like very
different from just seeing who's the
last to leave the office all of these
different things and yeah the whole idea
was to create this this kind of
blueprint and also take what you need
type thing that would be really
actionable but also was baked into
today's culture rather than being
like the stuff from back in the 2000s
that tells you to work x amount yeah i
love it make some money one of one of
the lines that i was listening to the
audiobook and when you said sometimes
productivity can be self-care yeah and i
was like oh that's interesting
what's what's going on with that so i
think that's one of the like one of the
main triggers for the book was actually
the fact that like people would be like
oh self-care relax and i'd be like
actually sometimes self-care is meeting
that deadline that you're currently not
on track to meet but actually
respecting your future self and your
goals is
getting the [ __ ] up and doing the work
that you need to do for that and like we
cannot market self-care as always like
doing nothing sometimes self-care is
working harder because you're currently
not working in line with what you want
to make happen and i think that again
the internet hates that because it's
like
it doesn't fit into this idea of like
well-being versus productivity
it's
the actual understanding of the fact
that both of one and the other like
self-care isn't always running a bath if
you're running a bath and you're about
to miss three deadlines and that's your
paycheck for the week self-care is not
running a bath i refuse to believe that
self-care is running a bath so that was
a lot of the stuff in the book is around
how to action actual self-care and like
how to know at what point something will
be self-care and some
versus self-sabotage or any of these
things to create a life that revolves
around you know your boundaries and
where you need to be more productive and
where you probably need to stop being so
harsh on yourself nice what are your uh
two different types of doing nothing yes
because i thought that was super
interesting like the distinction and i i
had one of those over the weekend it was
a saturday no no one else in the house i
was like i'm gonna make all this book
progress and i made zero book progress i
just browsed youtube all day and i was
listening to the audiobook last night i
was like oh if i had this terminology of
like [ __ ] nothing i would have called
it i would have just like written the
day off but i didn't and so i felt
guilty for the whole day
so yeah so i think that's really really
important and i think that when we're
taught so much how to work and we're not
taught that well how to
take time and
know when we're probably a little bit
burnt out and all of these different
things that actually if we took rest we
would be much better tomorrow the idea
of planned nothing and [ __ ] it nothing
are the fact that actually i believe
wholeheartedly in time management i
believe that time management is stress
management for some people you're going
to be very like taipei and it's going to
be like of course you're you're time
managing like of course at the beginning
of your week you know what your whole
week looks like and all of this other
people are going to be like no i won't
know till the day i do believe though
that if you want to fit a certain amount
of things in you have to be good at time
management and you have to do your 10
000 hours and make yourself good at time
management
you don't have to want to fine but do i
think that it's really important to also
give a bit of tough love and be like if
you want to do x y and z you have to pla
it's not going to happen without you
planning it so whether that's
starting to go to the gym whether that's
starting a new side hustle or a new
hobby or any of those things if you're
not planning those things in
in the same way as if you don't plan in
the gym or you know if you don't put
your doctor's appointment in your diary
it's not gonna happen so the idea of
like plan nothing and [ __ ] it nothing is
when you're looking at your weak plan
and you're doing all your day plan and
you're doing your plan for yourself i
think it's really important to have
enough planned nothing in there and i
don't think we do that because planning
nothing
again seems quite oxymoronic it doesn't
make sense but knowing your boundaries
and getting to know how you're most
productive and how you're happiest the
happiest is really really important and
that all comes then into your time
management so for me for example i know
that from a monday to thursday so
weekdays i'm probably going to want to
do something two nights
and do nothing two nights
and
that's my limit usually so like this
week i've had something every single
night and i hate it i feel dead i've
started every day feeling like an
absolute zombie i don't have any
thinking time i don't have time to stare
at the ceiling like i don't you know i'm
not able to kind of process things in
the same way and so i get anxious about
things and i get stressed and i don't
feel like
i'm my best self
the way we mitigate that is by
understanding those boundaries and for
me usually
if i look at next week for example and
i've got something in on wednesday and
thursday and someone says are you free
on tuesday i'm not i'm actually not free
on tuesday it might look if you looked
at my diary like i'm free but i'm not
these are my non-negotiables and this is
how i manage myself to be able to be my
best self for my goals whether those are
personal life whether those are work
[ __ ] it nothing
is
understanding that we can plan as much
as we want we can
operate by those rules we can you know i
can know that i'm going out wednesday
and thursday next week for dinner
and i can know that i'm doing tuesday
monday and tuesday in and then whatever
the weekend i've got it all planned and
i can get to wednesday
and i can be like i actually i actually
either don't want to or i can't or i'm
feeling really burnt out or my mental
health isn't there or any of those
things and understanding that we can
plan for absolutely everything and we
can't plan for the fact that we're human
and so [ __ ] it nothing is essentially
being able to be like [ __ ] it
not doing that and i think
important distinction again is like you
get a real dopamine hit when you think
you had to do something and then you
don't have to do something so you have a
plan with some someone and then you you
cancel that plan you get that dopamine
here but then also
you can get into the habit of doing that
because you think you need that and
actually what you needed was to push
yourself out there and go out to dinner
and have a good laugh with someone you
haven't caught up with in a while but it
feels like a chore when you're at the
end of that day and you're like that's
the last thing i want to do so i think
understanding as well the boundaries of
[ __ ] nothing too are really important
but i do think that if we don't have
[ __ ] it nothing say your saturday night
where you were going to make a huge
amount of progress with the book
and you decide not to what you really
needed in that time was [ __ ] nothing
you needed to be like [ __ ] it i'm doing
absolutely nothing
instead
you probably sat on the sofa being like
i'm meant to be doing something
and then felt
probably you probably didn't get the
benefit of doing nothing and you didn't
get the benefit of doing work and so i
think understanding our human limits and
our boundaries and being able to just
say i'm not going to do that and i know
i'm not going to do that and i'm okay
with not doing that is one of the most
important things you can do for your
productivity and your time management
and your self-care what's your process
for setting goals i feel like this is a
test on my book material i'm not sure if
it's in the book it is it's in chapter
four defining success [ __ ]
it's proof that i did write the book
okay people are always like you had a
ghostwriter i'm like the problem with
the ghostwriter is the fact that there's
nothing against having ghostwriter for
so many people it doesn't make sense for
them to write something but if it's
really bad i don't want to take credit
for writing it because i don't want you
to think it's really bad and if it's
really good i don't want to take credit
for writing it because i didn't do it so
i was like instantly they were like
ghostwriter and i was like i spent my
uni doing 10 000 words a week this is my
bag i'm like i can do this i can sit
down and write and half of it will be
[ __ ] but at least like the bit that will
end up in the end will hopefully be good
and hopefully that's been proved by the
fact that you know it's still still
selling well in all of this and i'm not
posting about it and all that anyway the
defining success thing i think the goal
setting again really really really
important it's kind of like long-term
time management it's like
setting we probably have in our head
these destinations that we
want to get to
and somewhere along the way that
destination will change but if we don't
acknowledge its change we're probably
like autopiloting towards that and we're
actually like
huh that's actually not what i want to
do anymore and i think goal setting as
much as it like comes across quite
woo-woo and wishy-washy
it's literally like the steer at
steering wheel to make sure you're going
in the right direction yeah yeah i think
it can come across in wishy-washy but
there's also another side of it which is
very much smart goal like yeah yeah like
25 percentage by like two weeks yeah
yeah exactly and so so i like mine to be
somewhere in between i like to have my
smart goals which
do we need to go through them what a
smart goal is you can google what's my
goal
um so so like a smart goal i like to
have those because i think it's really
important so i'll say i want to
you know have x amount more revenue
based on like last year from this or
whatever by this time but actually
a lot of my things because i'm
because you know we're reporting every
week and i do so much stuff that is like
measurable i try and do more
floaty goals too which i think is
important weirdly so what's a floaty
goal well just you know like i want to
by this time i want to feel like i've
made more progress towards this or i
want to feel more fulfilled in my
everyday because i am including more
hobbies or any of these things goal
setting wise i usually do
i'll do key points in the year
um i'll do year goal yearly goal setting
quarterly goal setting monthly goal
setting and weekly goal setting and
daily goal setting which sounds like i
probably sit there for like
five hours a day being like what do i
want my goals to be and never actually
doing the work and i think that if we
thought we spent half as much time
worrying about how like woo-woo doing
that much goal-setting
is we'd be getting to our goals a lot
quicker i think that you know
goal-setting can be as small as writing
down three non-negotiables that you're
going to do that day that's like that's
you're setting those three goals for
your day so i think that we don't need
to think of it as doing a scrap work
like vision board every day but i think
some direction is really really really
important so yearly goals that will be
split into kind of work goals personal
goals and i'll have some smart goals in
there and i'll also have some like
i just want to feel generally more like
this whereas like down to daily goals
every single day i will write three
non-negotiable things i'll do that day
like a year is
literally just three six five days and i
know that's so
it's obvious but it's also
that accumulation say if you're setting
monthly goals
you need to do things in that month
that's going to get towards those goals
and the i mean it's all the atomic habit
stuff like the the first thing that you
can do to do to the uh to get to those
are the small minute changes make the
biggest result so every single day i'll
have three non-negotiable things that i
am doing that day without fail and at
the same time you know in my weeks it
will be a bit broader in my months it
will be a bit broader but again i don't
spend more than you know probably 20
minutes on a monthly yearly i might
spend an hour and have a bit of a think
about it and all of that but daily
two minutes writing down my
non-negotiable goals but i think it's
really really really important i think
an example of that i would be you know
when we were talking about my career my
big goal when i was probably in second
year at university would be to have like
a big collaboration with a fast fashion
brand so that was what was happening
like the most successful kind of
youtubers and all of that were having
these collaborations with pretty little
thing boohoo
all of that and that was my like big
goal i was kind of just like aimlessly
working doing as much as i could like
all of these things and i kind of
realized like about nine months into the
year before goal setting for the next
year i was like not only is that not a
goal anymore i also actually wouldn't
take it if i was offered that like it's
it's so out of line and for those
changes to happen that you know there'll
be years where we have bigger shifts in
mindset than others like i don't have
that every year but i think actually
acknowledging and writing those things
down is it takes two seconds and it's so
so so important and i think a lot of the
time especially as we grow up
our priorities shift and we realize that
actually we don't want to make
10 grand extra we want to spend three
more days a week
with our friends you know all of those
different things so i think that
my goal setting is quite like granular i
don't think it always looks like goal
setting often it will just be about you
know good planning yeah yeah i think
that's i think my approach to goal
setting is similar where sometimes i'll
benefit from a smart goal and sometimes
i won't i'll just be like you know i got
a
full body dexa scan the other day
whereas like for the first time i'm
seeing like my body fat percentage
muscle mass and i found that like
ridiculously like liberating and
empowering and like yes motivating to
take gym more seriously but i know so
many people who would like that would be
the last thing on earth that they would
want because they don't want like
working out to be a numerical thing yeah
yeah it's like oh that's good oh no i do
because i judge myself entirely based on
like i need to be able to attribute
progress to some sort of measurable way
in terms of like rather than
you know the the healthy thing to do
would probably be say i'm going to make
sure i go to the gym four days a week
whereas if the aim of going to the gym
four days a week is to
lose weight for example it's like not a
current goal of mine but like say if
that was the thing i'd rather judge it
based on that so it will be i'm really
probably like i think a lot of type a
people are
are really concentrated on numbers so i
think for me it's often good to move
things away from that because while it's
a better way to reach a goal it's i'd
say
you probably know if you're a more
obsessive person and i know i am
what's your what's your balance between
i guess striving for goals versus
being satisfied and enjoying the present
moment
so i'm really good at one of them and
really bad at the other and i know that
and i work
very hard to change that perception as a
person i'm not good at
sitting down and enjoying the moment but
i also think that it's
probably
most to blame for when i am
unhappy or feeling unfulfilled or
feeling lost or any of those things so i
really really consciously try not to i
think that you're always going to lean
more one
way or the other and therefore you know
you always need to push yourself in one
way or the other so i don't need to push
myself to make goals
i need to push myself to
calm the [ __ ] down and enjoy the day or
like
let this month be this month and
you know because i'm always always
always looking to the next thing what i
can do better all of these things
at the same time you'll know if you know
say someone who will reply to a story
being like how do you get motivated
you're probably gonna need yourself to
like
go more towards goal-setting you're
probably quite good at enjoying the
moment and i just think that it the
balance there's no one balance and i
also think that like it's a hugely
privileged thing to say oh yeah you need
balance between work and life like
there's no balance between work and life
if you're working you know three jobs to
put food on the table for your kids
there's also no balance for you know if
i sat there being like work life balance
and like i've got a vc funded startup
and actually there's not a lot of work
life balance i've got to be realistic
about that my work life balance is
knowing that there's not that at the
moment but there you know hopefully will
be in the future and i can enjoy the
fact that it's not that in the moment
because i in an incredibly lucky
position to be able to do that yeah and
so
yeah there's i think that work-life
balance again is one of those things
that it's like so individual yeah and
you just need to know which way you need
to push yourself i guess final question
on this productivity front and we'll put
links to the book in all the things
people can check it out it's genuinely
very good um thank you
what are your personal signs and
symptoms of burnout like how do you know
when you're like encroaching burnout
territory or you're in burnout territory
and i guess like what does the word even
mean to you because people seem to have
different definitions of it so i talk
about it a lot in the book and i do
think that there's this difference
between clinical burnout which is a
really serious thing that you get signed
off work for that is a medical term
that is hugely debilitating all of this
and i also think that there is this kind
of idea of mini burnout and i would say
that a lot of people
now
have mini burnout because where you
don't leave work at the office if you
have an office you definitely don't
leave work at the office if you work
from home
you also even if you then think you do
going on social media say every time i
go on social media i'll probably see
five different activewear competitors
i'll probably see
50 different influencers who are doing
better content than i do i will probably
see 10 different friends who have more
successful
relationships fashion senses like what
all of these things we are working in
some way
all the time
and i think that it's like that's why
these older generations look at us and
they're like oh [ __ ] boohoo like
you've got
access to social media and it's burning
you out because you're looking at other
people's clothes but i do think it's
really it's the same as talking about
the 24-hour news cycle it is our brains
are never fully relaxed and therefore
they never get full response respite in
order to reset
and
you know go again like if you're swiping
through tick tock every night before bed
your brain is not going to rest in the
same way and you're fatiguing yourself
and i do think that a lot of and that's
not to say that you know i don't do that
sometimes and i will be the first to say
that i have so much advice and i take
absolutely none of it but i also think
that
we as a generation are increasingly
burnt out based on the fact that work
doesn't just look like work emails just
aren't just on a computer your office
isn't just on an office
your phone isn't just a phone like all
of these things
and i think that you know the aim of the
book was to give also a certain amount
of tools to deal with that i think my
signs in particular of burnout
are i think i've been slightly burnt out
for a very long time now i think i've
probably been slightly burnt out
as soon as i even started slowing down
the the social media stuff which was
originally i think i only realized that
when i did slow it down i was like oh my
god
this time it's not like feeling like
i've got a lot of time back it's just
feeling like a bit of a breath of fresh
air just because i was also doing the
degree at the same time and
also bombarded with so many opinions
positive negative all the same like
and i think that i've never actually
fully recovered from that and i think
that it's also part of the fact that we
don't talk about one of the downfalls of
passions is that if you're working on
your passion you're probably not going
to realize when you're burnt out because
there's this like necessity whether
internal or external because it's a
business that you put a lot of money
into or internal because you believe in
it so much and you love it and you
really want to succeed
it's like when you're working for ages
and you don't realize until you look up
how long you've been working for and
you're really like your whole brain's
just zapped and i think that we don't
talk about how
exhausting working on something you're
passionate about can be
because you exert yourself that much
more now that's not to say that as like
i've mentioned it's not to say that it's
not a hugely privileged position because
it is but i also think that when we're
encouraging like work on your passion
like all of this also remembering the
fact that if you're there every day so
trying to make this idea into a business
and so trying to make this work and so
trying to get your side hustle off the
ground and all of these things you're
also allowed to feel
burnt out and like it's a lot and i
think giving myself permission to do
that has been a big learning curve i
don't think i'm quite there yet but
actually acknowledging that especially
because my a lot of my job is online
burnout is not necessarily just going to
be mitigated by
working less
first of all
i often can't do that because first of
all you know we have vc investors i'm
contracted to things i want to make
things happen like all of these
different things
but also i
i think that the even if i worked less
you know any one time for a week
i'm still gonna probably be in some way
on social media or consuming people's
opinions or seeing people's like
activewear in the street whatever it
might be
one of the most valuable things i've
implemented for myself is just really
really understanding where my boundaries
are and understanding where they shift
as well because my boundaries from one
year to the next aren't going to be the
same my boundaries from winter to summer
aren't going to be the same i'm going to
be able to work a lot harder and not
feel like i'm missing out in winter than
i am in summer and just giving myself
the respect to
know that
of course i need to work hard and i do
work incredibly hard and i don't think i
need pushing in that direction i think
that anyone who knows me knows that and
actually
knowing that i'm probably more the way i
need to mother myself is just be like no
get in the bath
you won't and also not on your phone
like reading is one of the biggest ways
i relax and not non-fiction books don't
buy my book it's fiction books and you
know reading novels because you can't
concentrate on anything else and finding
those things that take you completely
away from the reality of like work and
life and everything i think is so
important
grace thank you so much it's been a
fantastic conversation i'd love to get
some fiction book recommendations what's
oh what's up can i actually get up my
lips please yes i would i would love
that i'm i'm huge on uh fantasy these
days but i'm keen to explore other
genres as well so
for anyone watching this is my
succinct
novel list
for the best summer of your life
sick um these are the gripping or
life-changing ones educated by tara
westover
the nightingale by kirsten hanna
small great things by jody pickholt the
storyteller also by jodie picolt i am
pilgrim by terry hayes
and
eleanor oliphant is completely fine by
gail honeyman i think those are really
good books that none of them are sure to
read okay girly and fun i assume you're
very much into this genre very much so
we've got twilight over there somewhere
great one directions
these are all fantastic okay the seven
husbands of evelyn hugo daisy jones and
the six grown-ups malibu rising the flat
share the break and seven days in june
i've heard the flat share have you i
really enjoyed that so good i don't know
how it came across it but it was i read
in one sitting really good all of those
ones are like that they're kind of like
if the sensation you have is similar to
watching a really good tv series
it's fun it's funny it's not a chore
and it just makes sense really important
and then i'd say
thrillers sharp objects
behind closed doors and the night she
disappeared that was just the summer
reading list i wrote for my instagram
amazing but i genuinely think that a lot
of those things are
so
they're such good books and i think that
everyone should read more are you
audible or kindle or physical book which
came for you
if i have the book then physical book or
if i i go to i love like second-hand
bookstores and all that kindle though
most of the time because portable any
any non-fiction books you'd recommend
other than potentially oh yeah again i
actually have a huge non-fiction reading
list in the back of the back of my book
so you can probably go into a bookstore
and not even buy it and get all my
recommendations
all in the show notes oh wow that's a
big yeah and it's categorized as well
because that's how i live my life
memoirs oh hello
podcast online resources tim ferriss
show yes
oh there's a lot of stuff here okay if
you had to
you had to pick like three non-fiction
books
um
potentially so obviously atomic habits i
assume you've read that
i would say black box thinking oh i
haven't heard that
um there's also a really good murky book
series which is like mini books they're
like a how-to series they have like how
to build it for like building your brand
how to change it for activism how to
write it with like books how to calm it
like how to move it like all of these
things really good how to fix your
finances all of it all of those things
rework i think is really good um
guys
the ones who used to be google
rework
jason friedrich oh yeah yeah yeah
so yeah really good i think particularly
if you have a company in terms of the
way things work obviously start with why
um for our work week um i say in this
book i don't agree with everything it
says um but i think it's really
important to read
um
the working woman's handbook i think
incredibly important is special
especially for creatives and freelancers
that's phoebe love that trick mirror by
gia tolentino oh my god that is one of
my favorite books ever i will happily
it's a series of essays which sounds
like the most boring thing ever if
anyone tells me anything essays i'm like
goodbye and then i read them and they're
amazing but that one is like a series of
essays on modern culture and they are
both hilarious and so observant and
written in a way that i didn't even know
could be written oh my god i'm actually
rework was not what i was thinking it
was that's work rules you're yeah
work rules is the google one i would say
those are the main ones thank you so
much this is great
that's okay all right so that's it for
this week's episode of deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are gonna be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the itunes store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full hd or
4k on youtube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye